THEY WILL HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
THINGS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY REPRESENTS
MISSOURI IN THE U.S. SENATE.
THANKS FOR JOINING US, SENATOR
HAWLEY.
YOU TALKED ABOUT IN A TWEET
RECENTLY ABOUT HOW IT'S TIME FOR
A CHANGE IN THE GOP, THAT IT'S
TIME FOR NEW LEADERSHIP IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
HAVING SERVED IN CONGRESS FOR
EIGHT YEARS, I KNOW HOW MUCH
PRESSURE THERE IS FOR MEMBERS OF
BOTH PARTIES TO FOLLOW
LEADERSHIP.
GO IN LOCK STEP, VOTE PARTY
LINE.
I THINK THAT IS -- THERE'S A LOT
OF DIFFERENT ISSUES.
WHAT KIND OF LEADERSHIP DO YOU
ISSUE FOR THE NEW REPUBLICAN
PARTY THAT GIVES PEOPLE THE
FREEDOM TO VOTE THEIR CONSCIOUS?
>> WE NEED GOOD STRONG
INDEPENDENT LEADERSHIP THAT
LISTENS TO VOTERS AND NOT JUST
THE WASHINGTON LOBBYISTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE GOP, THE
WASHINGTON REPUBLICANISM THAT
CARING MORE ABOUT WALL STREET,
IT TIME FOR THAT TO COME TO AN
END T WASHINGTON REPUBLICANISM
THAT IS ABOUT ADVENTURES A BROAD
AND THE NEOCONSERVATISM BASED ON
WORKING PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY,
IT NEEDS TO COME TO AN END.
WHAT VOTERS ARE ASKING US TO DO
IS CLEAR.
SECURE OUR STREETS.
LET'S PUT 100,000 COPS ON THE
STREET.
STOP THE INDOCTRINATION OF OUR
CHILDREN AND BRING JOBS BACK TO
THIS COUNTRY.
IT USED TO BEEN ON ONE GOOD
WAGE.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT ANYMORE.
THAT HAS TO COME TO AN END.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO BE THE ONES
FOR THE WORKING CLASS CULTURE.
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FIGHTING
FOR.
>> SENATOR HAWLEY, WHEN WE LOOK
AT HOW MANY PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN
SHOW UP TO VOTE AT ALL ON THIS
LAST ELECTION DAY, THAT ALONE
SENDS A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
WE'RE NOT HEARING THE PUNDITS
ADDRESS, WHICH IS PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE TRUST THAT THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE PUBLIC SERVANT THERE'S IN
WASHINGTON.
WE'RE FIGHTING FOR THEM, NOT NOR
THE PARTY BUT FOR THEM TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
IF YOU DIDN'T LOOK AT WHO SHOWED
UP, INDEPENDENTS THAT DON'T LIKE
JOE BIDEN AND THEY VOTED FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA BACK IN THE DAY,
VOTED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY LOOKED AT THE OPTIONS.
I DON'T LIE BIDEN AT ALL AND I
DON'T TRUST THE REPUBLICANS.
THE REPUBLICANS WEREN'T SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO SECURITY THE
BORDER.
WE NEED LEADERSHIP IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN WASHINGTON.
THIS IS WHY I WON'T SUPPORT
MITCH McCONNELL FOR LEADER.
WE NEED NEW LEADERSHIP AND REAL
CONVICTIONS.